james corden he's not american but he is
fantastic he's bringing the late late
show to london this week for the last
time i say big sigh on that the host has
confirmed he'll be leaving a show here
on cbs next summer he has an all-star
lineup for the show this week but first
our charlie dagger to turn the tables on
cordon in the country where he was born
[Applause]
james corden has taken the show on the
road and across the pond it is so great
to be back to be in my hometown
returning to london for the first time
in three years and the last time ever
and we got a chance to switch sides with
the star mr james corden how are you
welcome to the show this is wonderland
welcome
i've never done this before neither have
i i've never done wow i've always wanted
quite the experience how does it feel
well i understand now when guests say
this isn't a very comfy couch it isn't
it's true
among the london leg features carpool
karaoke with lizzo and a segment from
the oval office as the president's pa
mr president well how are you i'm very
well so good to see you
but gordon will soon be bowing out this
will be
this will be my last year hosting the
late nation calling it a day on late
night after an eight-year run
i don't know if i'll ever truly realize
what we
did with this show how far the odds were
stacked against us and how we just
managed to somehow pull it off it seems
like you're getting emotional
how can you not it would be
i i i
it would be weird not to be where i was
so
absolutely definite in my head that we
would be on the air for
three months and then be fired it was it
wasn't it wasn't an if it was a when
instead the late late show and the host
himself a relative unknown in the us
went stratospheric in part by blowing up
the internet the carpool karaoke with
adele alone racked up more than 250
million views
and there aren't many people on the
planet who get invited to joyride in a
jet with tom cruise
but there is one particular highlight
that struck a chord with corden the
carpal karaoke with paul mccartney in
liverpool
i sort of knew when we were doing it
that we might be
capturing something special
i remember turning to my best friend ben
who's the exec producer of the show and
saying that's the best thing we'll ever
shoot if my granddad was here right now
i get an absolute kick out of this
he is
like all of these things you're like if
these were auction prizes i think they'd
go for millions and millions of dollars
if if an auction prize was tom cruise
will fly you around in a fighter jet
and he'll be maverick and you can be
goose but james
my friend yes
that brings us to the big question
why why are you leaving us
i don't know what else we can do
we can't
jump out of another plane with tom
cruise or
drive down penny lane singing penny lane
with paul mccartney or
shoot carpal karaokes with adele and
the first lady you have to make a
decision and go
i never ever wanted this to be something
i was ever bored with or just the thing
that i do
whether the next thing he does takes
place in america or takes him back here
to britain he won't say but late late
night won't be the same without someone
like james
for cbs mornings charlie dagetta london
he is going to be so missed i'm so glad
we still have another year guess who he
really wants for carpool karaoke the one
person he hasn't gotten who's that yes
queen bee
oh beyonce oh that would be i so hope
she'll do it i still hope she'll do it
in his final year he's gotten everybody
else that he wanted but he's left us
with such a legacy what i think is so
great is we didn't know who he was right
never heard of him and now everybody
adores this man myself included yeah